uh okay donald trump has started
the pardons while he's continuing the
pardons uh speculation
for several weeks about exactly when a
flurry of pardons and commutations would
come from donald trump speculation
continues about
the pre-emptive pardons trump is said to
be considering for rudy giuliani
and his children his son-in-law jared
kushner
and many many others but there are now
15 or so more pardons and commutations
issued yesterday by donald trump now as
far as the russia probe
remember the one that led to all sorts
of arrests and indictments
um donald trump has pardoned his own
former
foreign policy advisor george
papadopoulos
who was found guilty of lying to federal
investigators as well as alex
vanderzwaan who was the dutch lawyer who
also lied to investigators
in connection with the russia
investigation so slowly but surely
donald trump is pardoning everybody who
was wrapped up in the mueller probe it's
a sort of revisionist history
the the investigation did find lots of
crimes they like to claim
it didn't but in any case trump will
just keep pardoning everybody and in a
way
retroactively wipe the slate clean even
those folks were
convicted and a pardon uh a part of
you know this is a kind of a bigger
legal debate but if you're pardoned then
you're conceding you were guilty now you
could say well it was an unfair guilty
verdict then you can make that case
a donald trump also pardoning former
republican congressman duncan hunter
former republican congressman chris
collins
four blackwater mercenaries involved
in an iraqi massacre that's an entire
other story we previously covered
two border patrol agents convicted in
2006
for shooting and wounding an unarmed
undocumented immigrant and then actually
covering it up
just a horrible signal that that sends
uh trump con
pardoned several people convicted of
non-violent drug crimes who were serving
long sentences that i agree with
trump also pardoning alfonso costa
a dentist who pleaded guilty to health
care fraud
alfred lee crum who pleaded guilty
to illegally distilling moonshine 70
years ago
weldon angelos who was sentenced to 55
years
for selling marijuana and carrying a
handgun
a philip lyman county commissioner in
utah who was sentenced to 10 days in
jail
because of his protest on atv
restrictions on federal land
okay and otis gordon who was convicted
of possession with intent to distribute
also philip s formus a florida nursing
home mogul
convicted for paying bribes in a
medicare fraud case
also had some of his sentence commuted
by trump and in addition to the pardons
a number of commutations the remaining
prison term of former
congressman steve stockman that's the
texas republican convicted
for almost two dozen felonies including
fraud and money laundering
and trump saying that uh because
stockman is 64
with underlying pre-existing conditions
he's at greater risk
during covid and he already got covered
while in prison what's interesting about
that is
trump says hey i'm good now because i
got coveted but even though
this guy already got coveted and
recovered it's still a reason to pull
him from prison
a little bit incoherent but it is trump
after all so the big picture here
is number one this is likely to be just
the start of donald trump's pardons
number two this is a separate
uh path it's a separate topic um
than the pre-emptive pardons being
considered
for his family members people like jared
kushner
ivanka don jr eric trump and we've
learned over the last seven to ten days
the possible reasons they would benefit
from a preemptive pardon
jared kushner potentially already being
investigated
for uh creating this shell company
through which
hundreds of millions of dollars in
campaign donations may have been
laundered
rudy giuliani reportedly talking to
trump about a preemptive pardon etc but
here is the clear trend and actually
listen to this data point
harvard law school professor jack
goldsmith looked at trump's pardons
so far and found that 88
of the pardons so far are for people
either personally tied
to trump or people whose actions
furthered trump's political aims or
protected him in some way
now presidents have absolute pardon
power we know that
trump has repeated that often it's not
really in question legally speaking the
issue here
is that it's always more corrupt with
trump
so many of the pardons are for crimes
committed by people
connected to trump or even people who
helped trump by the crimes they
committed including lying to
investigators
ostensibly to protect donald trump in
the mueller probe
so we can have a broader debate about
pardons in general
and we've had that debate and that's not
really the topic here
with trump there's always he's able to
dial up the corruption and cronyism just
a little bit
or even significantly and that's exactly
what he's done here and we'll
wait and see what the full list of
pardons is i want to take a second to
tell you
about one of our sponsors s h masks
snh masks has everything you need when
it comes to
face masks and other protective gear
for covid19 and they're giving my
audience 20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell and that's actually
why i reached out to them
about being a sponsor i've tried tons of
different face masks this year like many
of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on
the skin has a convenient adjustable
strap
they also have disposable cloth masks
which are really comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers
and all of their prices are very
reasonable i also love
snh masks because they've donated over
60 000 masks to health care institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks
and shipping is free on orders over a
hundred and fifty dollars
you can get there by going to
davidpakman.com
mask the link is under this video and
you can save 20
on everything in their store when you
use the coupon code
david